[Applaudissements]
la seconde
voilà vous inquiété par une remontée
parce que sam écrase les coucous il a
attendu après les faits cette année
est-ce qu'on peut pas le remonter un peu
le mois montrent un peu il faut leur
remontée s'il vous plaît madame vous
êtes salti remonter les coucougnettes
merci on s'en va là merci tu travailles
avec non seulement des gouttes j'allais
faire ça y est c'est bon là c'est là ses
parents
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est gagné
y a plus chez nous y'a que chez nous que
ça se rate ça se passe toujours mal sans
rigoler non non ce combat est la plus
mal de nous
tu n'as pas d'annoncé papeete mathieu
non non non non non non non là il a
gagné vous ne faites pas putté mathieu
je vous plais à l'émotion liée au betis
a cependant il ya des règles
ouais je viens d quoi
[Rires]
non
non non non non non non vous longerez
ans enlevée moi ça allait